right and there's a mechanism it comes
and all and they have like a little
cylindrical thing where there's like
yellow goo that comes out of the whale's
brain right
that
gives human beings long life the ability
not to age not to age so is it worth it
so it's like just basically collagen
yeah no but this like will extend
somebody's life right
yeah so you feel like that's I didn't
feel as bad
because you would pay 80 million for
that I don't know I don't know would you
the serum's worth 80 million that's what
they were yeah 80 million right yeah so
you kind of go uh I mean would you if if
whale brain serum gave you an extra 40
years of life
is it worth killing that's the
discussion it depends you walk into
Sephora or whatever well no if I'm just
yeah and I'm the lady at Sephora I'm
wearing the black go ahead right hi um
do you want brain juice from Pandora
from Wales what does it do what does it
do well I'll do the actor with you
because I feel like you're not in the
sketch right yeah I don't understand
like I didn't watch the movie so yeah
well okay so ideally basically let's
take it I get it I get it I get it I get
it just but go ahead what can you be
your friend in the sketch or no yeah
okay you play the opposing hey ladies
what's up what's up my name is Raman and
guess what we just got brand new brain
serum from Pandora oh my God yeah and
it's like for a little while it's 3.5
million hear me out what is it
40 Years first of all it's going to take
30 years off your life into in your face
you're going to look 30 years younger
love it right it's going to give you 40
years extended life right and it's only
for 3.5 million um
do you want to know how it's extracted
yeah I feel like you're really pushing
an agenda here yeah yeah yeah well the
bad news is that we brutally kill these
symbiotic whales brutally yeah brutally
and for their babies oh okay yeah you
have to do that but and we go inside the
mouth and we do this whole thing you
know I mean I'm not a scientist so I
don't know but anyway
um would you like to buy Saab
interesting let me confide with uh
Janice Janice go ahead well as you know
I work for Greenpeace you do I forgot
you're also well conservative a whale
conservator you work for grapes yeah and
I don't know if you've seen that show on
um I think I don't know if it's called
Whale Wars uh uh did you just are you a
producer on Wheels wait hold on do you
work for green beast and you're a
producer I will what explain the premise
as well I thought that Sephora was kind
of pushing like a clean agenda that's
true they don't test on it
actually I don't hey wait a second yeah
I mean they're about to keep me out now
but I always like set up my little um
I set up shop here you know what I mean
but oh they're telling me to leave hi a
guy he just said something yeah
and also I'm like seven foot six and I'm
Blue
look we eat
I don't know I don't know I know that's
brutal the way yeah yeah you're right
you're right but I would do I don't know
it's brutal it's pretty brutal but the
movie was great there are cultures and
you know that where you eat a whale
blubber whale meat seal meat because
that is what is most readily available
to them where they live geographically
and you know like I don't hold any
judgments because over here we eat pig
cow yeah chicken so it's like that's
available to us where we live and other
people live more sustainably by catching
what's you know in their environment
that's an interesting question so do you
think that if a pig or a cow could
actually speak
that we would still eat them
I don't think we would until that
changes it a bit because then you're
talking about something very similar to
us with that kind of brain yeah with
that intelligence because you know
there'll be like a Martin Luther King
Cow
you'll do a c okay okay all right no
he'll do a speed yeah I mean
yeah
no he can speak oh it's right yeah four
acres and three Farms ago you know what
I mean and you'll do a speech and it'll
inspire a whole CL all the cows cows
right and they'll revolt and also
they'll be liberals listening to them
and go we can't do it anymore yeah
that's true right don't you think if a
pig goes hey don't kill me my name is
John
you wouldn't do it there goes all your
Korean dishes
but crank house and pigs maybe is
different no they don't speak they don't
speak English
[Laughter]
have you guys seen the menu